without those other people I'm just a
guy who did pretty well in dailies that
day all right
so every movie we've ever done sorry but
there okay fine yeah yeah yeah
yeah like like you're the star of the
CBS Morning Show I'm nuts about that
John Dickerson weren't you
I am - yeah there you go we had a John
Dickerson love fest because it's not the
point John was making is he can't do it
without the team around him I was
talking to you're an oscar-nominated
Akron goes yeah yeah yeah but I have
screenwriters I have makeup I have
directors and I said yeah but it's you
he goes no no and that's what led to
that exchange he's nuts about you John
Dickerson that was oscar-winning actor
Tom Hanks he's one too but nominated for
many many more giving kudos to the
people behind the scenes of his movies
and praising the one and only John
Dickerson so I was with Tom last night
here in New York City for an event at
the 92nd Street Y community and cultural
center his book came out in paperback
and so that's why we were having the
conversation but we talked about his
career and his other creative passion
writing Tom Hanks is set to star in a
biopic as the iconic Mister Rogers
which hits theaters next year it was a
filming of this movie that moved Hanks
to send a heartfelt message to the city
of Pittsburgh in the aftermath of the
tragedy mr. Rogers was filmed in
Pittsburgh because that's where he was
yes it was you all know there's a
terrible terrible deadly story tragic
story in Pittsburgh and shortly after
you filmed we had that terrible shooting
at the synagogue and I remember seeing
you last week and you said I actually
know that Sena God yes and you tweeted
about it it made national news you said
again it says love thy neighbor no
exceptions again to me this photo is the
spirit of Pittsburgh with a broken heart
today for those in Squirrel Hill so used
to see that synagogue all the time well
that wasn't the synagogue that that sign
was this isn't the sets of churches
that's up on Mount Washington if you
know Pittsburgh you take the incline up
you walk around and that was a big that
but the Tree of Life synagogue is in
Squirrel Hill doubly shot at the studios
of WQED yeah where mr. Rogers actually
shot his his and we drove past that
synagogue
16 times in the course of while we're
there we always thought oh what a great
name for a synagogue and
but the fact that you tweeted about it I
thought touched a lot of people well
yeah what can you do in the face of it I
will tell you this I will tell you this
mr. Fred rod we keep calling a mr.
Rogers you know Fred Fred Rogers people
would ask him the you know questions
like the great the great imponderables
and the ironies of life and one of the
questions he was asked has always been
what do we do in times of great struggle
or great horror and mr. Rogers said as
only he could he said look to the
helpers yes a horrible thing has
happened but you cannot give up hope and
if you need a source of hope look to the
helpers look to the people who come in
immediately and start passing out food
and taking care of things or help
organize the thing and that is in a lot
of ways that's the extraordinary thing
about let's just let's just narrow down
all of Western civilization to the
United States of America when that
happens in earthquakes in Los Angeles or
typhoons tomorrow or in the course of
such bloodshed and horror has happened
in Squirrel Hill everybody comes out and
helps and guess what you it is possible
to love thy neighbor with no exceptions
we can be good at that if we choose to
be we can be and it is a choice I think
kindness matters and I think we needed
Mountain more now than ever
Tom Hanks believes in this country he
says we will be alright you know he was
gonna say helpers well that's he he's
he's got the dead gene inside him